[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu queria compartilhar com vocês uma
história que me marcou muito
era o primeiro dia de aula de um curso
que eu fiz alguns anos atrás
na hora que eu entrei na sala as
cadeiras estavam organizadas em círculo
e os alunos assim como eu e eu chegando
e sentando até que entram os dois
professores leiam o texto e ficam em
silêncio
só que esse silêncio durou horas
todo mundo começou a se olhar sem
entender o que estava acontecendo e sem
saber o que fazer
alguns alunos até tentavam propor
dinâmicas mas que não iam pra frente
porque visivelmente a turma esperava uma
atitude dos professores
aquele silêncio de vez em quando é
interrompido por comentários indignados
de estar naquela situação perdendo tempo
eu saí de lá reflexiva pensando o que
deveria ter feito nesse tempo livre
porque não fui capaz de fazer nada o que
eu faço quando não tem ninguém me
dizendo o que eu devo fazer bom na época
que eu fiz esse curso eu trabalhava no
marketing de uma multinacional e tinha
uma angústia que me acompanhava anos
eu sentia que desperdiçava minha vida em
um trabalho que não fazia sentido pra
mim uma coisa que representava bem esse
meu sentimento era essa a caneca que que
usava no trabalho
eu me sentia como esse pássaro preso em
uma gaiola em quanto tempo passava
uma vez eu comentei isso com o colega e
ele falou pra mim assim tenile você viu
que a porta da gaiola aberta
bom essa porta sempre né
eu é que não queria olhar muito pra ela
porque eu não sabia o que fazer se eu
saísse da linha
só que chega uma hora que essa situação
ficou insustentável
eu decidi que eu ia abrir mão dessa
gaiola comecei a guardar dinheiro
planejar uma longa viagem que talvez me
dessa inspiração do que fazer no futuro
e quando a contagem regressiva começou
eu ficava imaginando que maravilha o dia
em que eu estiver livre para fazer
qualquer coisa para estar em qualquer
lugar do mundo
bom né nem tanto
sabe o que eu sentir quando finalmente
eu estava livre pânico e aflição
aquela não era nem de perto a sensação
de estar de férias eu queria logo
certezas
eu queria respostas eu queria um
direcionamento um caminho claro que me
dessem garantias
agora vejam só que interessante essas
duas experiências aquela do primeiro dia
daquele curso e essa angústia de estar
livre me sinalizavam a minha total e
absoluta falta de habilidade e lidar com
uma situação onde eu não tinha
instruções claras a serem seguidas
onde eu precisava fazer escolhas e lidar
com as consequências dessas escolhas e
aí sabe que eu comecei a lembrar e
talvez alguns de vocês se identifiquem
que desde criança eu nunca precisei
fazer muitas escolhas
aliás era melhor que eu não quisesse
escolher nem questionar nada
a escola me dava instruções muito claras
de como me comportar e a mim cabe apenas
obedecer e depois quando eu cresci
o cenário mudou obviamente mas algumas
coisas continuaram muito parecidas
eu ainda fazia parte de uma estrutura
que de certa forma me dava clareza do
que fazer e assim eu nunca me senti
muito perdida eu tinha um escopo de
trabalho definido eu tenho horários para
cumprir o tinha regras a serem seguidas
e foi aí que eu comecei a refletir sobre
o impacto do sistema escolarizado na
minha vida adulta e eu fiquei curiosa
quando ouve falar de modelos inovadores
de educação que estavam surgindo pelo
mundo
eu fui pesquisar escolas que estavam
justamente focadas em um modelo de
ensino que desenvolve habilidades e
atitudes e com isso indivíduos mais
autónomos e preparados para a vida eu
coloquei duas dessas escolas no roteiro
de viagem que estava começando
ando ea partir daí a minha viagem
começou a ganhar um sentido mais claro a
minha primeira parada foi na indonésia
ali eu passei um semestre em uma escola
que tem assim uma visão muito modesta
inspirar empoderar seus alunos de 40
diferentes países a assumir a liderança
por um mundo mais sustentável
não por caso essa escola que chama o
risco fica no meio da natureza ea inter
é construída de bambu
mas mais do que isso o que eu achei mais
interessante ele é o fato de não existir
parede sem nenhum espaço em uma sala de
aula
ali eu percebi paredes não são só as
barreiras físicas mas também
psicológicas e que o espaço sem paredes
expande as nossas possibilidades permite
a exploração à experimentação que quer
ver como olha só a quantidade de coisas
que eu vi acontecendo ali diariamente
eu senti o cheiro de comida das crianças
cozinhando a cantoria entusiasmada que
vinha da sala de teatro o som do tambor
da marimba do gamelão mas também tinha
silêncio da meditação das aulas de yoga
os cuidados com a horta
ali eu vi gente pequena debatendo o
assunto de gente grande
questões sociais em entrar e e thais são
trabalhadas em projetos sérios junto com
a comunidade e com ongs locais e às
vezes expressadas pela arte através da
poesia do teatro da pintura
nessa escola e houve espaço para os mais
diversos talentos desabrocharem então eu
parei e pensei como teria sido a minha
vida
se eu tivesse estudado em uma escola
como essa será que não teria descoberto
os meus talentos as minhas habilidades e
até o meu propósito mais cedo se eu
tivesse vivenciado todas essas
experiências
ali é assim mesmo que o aprendizado
acontece primeiro vivenciando as
experiências
olha só o que estava acontecendo com a
turma da pré escola
as formigas entravam e comiam o seu
lanche
então a professora
uma ideia genial vamos criar um
restaurante para as formigas lá fora
às vezes as crianças ficaram eufóricas
elas em o tempo inteiro lá pra ver se as
formigas já tinham chegado até que uma
delas sai correndo não sendo a grande
descoberta da sua vida a formiga como
açúcar e à medida que as crianças
crescem esse aprendizado através da
experiência ele se torna mais elaborado
tinha um grupo de alunos que estava
pesquisando comércio de barbatanas de
tubarão em bali que está levando os
animais em extinção
eles foram até o mercado do peixe pra
ver se isso era real e quando chegaram a
se depararam com centenas de tubarões
que tinham sido capturados pelos
pescadores
eles ficaram chocados com aquela cena e
começaram a refletir que é que ele não é
o mercado do peixe e do outro lado do
mundo
aquilo estava acontecendo muito próximo
deles e isso gerou um senso de
responsabilidade uma necessidade de agir
então a primeira coisa que eles fizeram
foi negociar com os pescadores alguns
tubarões que eles conseguiram levar para
um santuário numa ilha próxima e depois
soltar de volta no mar durante o
mergulho de cilindro
eles também ficaram pensando em como
gerar outras fontes de renda para os
pescadores e como conscientizar a
população a não consumir a sopa de
barbatana de tubarão que estava gerando
esse problema
uma outra situação esse professor
o professor um professor chamado nó quer
pessoa com quem eu gostava muito de
conversar na escola ele criou um módulo
chamado utopia distopia e colocou os
alunos na condição de habitantes de uma
sociedade fictícia do final do século 21
ali eles precisavam encontrar um papel
na sociedade encontra formas de gerar
renda e lidar com as incertezas que
surgiam como o tsunami ea crise dos
refugiados
aí o nome contou que quando ele inclui
os refugiados na história ele achava que
os alunos fossem ser super acolhedores
mas ao invés disso vieram perguntas como
quanto isso vai custar
vou ter que abrir mão do meu próprio
espaço então debates reais começarão a
acontecer na sala de aula sobre esse
assunto
e todo mundo percebeu que o problema era
muito mais complexo e difícil de
resolver do que parecia simplesmente
lendo uma notícia no jornal
depois de ter vivenciado e presenciado
essas e outras histórias na raiz kun
eu fui para a índia e ali eu passei um
mês em uma escola chamada universide
onde foi fundado um programa que hoje
está em 45 países e é uma metodologia
muito simples de quatro etapas para
envolver as crianças em projetos e
tornar essas crianças protagonistas de
histórias de mudança portar na cidade de
gandhi viveu por muitos anos também
busca inspiração na idéia da
responsabilidade individual que cada um
deve promover na sociedade as mudanças
que deseja para o mundo olha só o que
estava acontecendo nas primeiras semanas
que estava lá eu usava o transporte
escolar junto com as crianças e os
professores e eu percebi que todos os
dias os alunos do 7º ano desciam uns
dois quilômetros antes da escola e um
caminhão até lá com suas mochilas
sabe por que isso essa é uma forma deles
valorizarem o trabalho dos motoristas de
ônibus e no começo foi divertidíssimo
mas a pedida é que o tempo começou a
passar 30 dias em que chovia outros em
que fazia muito sol e começou a ficar
chato mas foi assim que eles sentiram na
pele como era a vida de tantas crianças
na índia que não têm acesso ao
transporte escolar
durante essas semanas ele chamar os
motoristas para uma conversa e fizeram
perguntas como quantas horas vocês
trabalham por dia
quais são os principais quando vocês
gostam do trabalho que fazem
quais são os principais problemas que
vocês enfrentam durante o trabalho e
nessa conversa eles descobriram três
coisas que gritar o ônibus colocar o
braço para fora da janela e colar
chiclete embaixo do banco eram coisas
que definitivamente não agradava os
motoristas a partir daí a missão deles
era rever os seus comportamentos e
também incentivar os colegas das outras
turmas
é o mesmo mas depois de ouvir essas
histórias pode ser que alguns de vocês
ainda estejam pensando mas e daí
que resultados sugerem na prática
então vou compartilhar uma ótima
história de dois alunos que são da globo
school que fundaram em 2013 um projeto
chamado nalu essa é uma marca de roupas
social e ecologicamente correta de
produção orgânica
mas mais do que isso este empreendimento
social e 50% do lucro revertido para a
compra de uniformes de crianças na índia
que de outra forma precisariam sair da
escola
eu conversei com a dale que é uma das
fundadoras e ela me contou essa conversa
os principais desafios que teve o que
que estava tendo durante esse desde que
ela iniciou o projeto e as coisas que
mais gostava de fazer que era criar as
peças de roupa porque ela adora moda
conversar com as pessoas e incentivar os
colegas a fazer aquilo que eles amam e o
mais gratificante de tudo quando ela vê
a felicidade das crianças na índia ao
receber esses uniformes no final da
nossa conversa com a sua sabedoria do
auge dos seus 15 anos
ela me fala da importância da gente
fazer aquilo que ama porque isso é o
melhor para o mundo e me pergunta porque
se não fizermos isso qual o sentido da
vida
eu me emocionei dessa conversa com a
dale e fiquei pensando na potência dessa
educação que leva as crianças a agir
desde cedo e agir para mudar o mundo
qual é a mágica por trás de uma educação
que revela talentos desenvolve
habilidades faz as crianças se colocarem
no lugar dos outros
gera reflexão questionamento e move por
ação pra mim ficou evidente a
importância das experiências reais na
vida real mas sim ao invés disso a gente
se acomoda com respostas prontas e
cresce cercadas de incertezas
quantas oportunidades que exigem um
primeiro passo no escuro
nós podemos desperdiçá durante nossa
vida adulta pelo medo do desconhecido
por não ter certeza de que os resultados
vão surgir das nossas ações e assim a
gente pode ficar paralisado diante de
decisões e oportunidades que são
fundamentais importantes na nossa vida
se eu tivesse esperado por certezas
provavelmente estaria ainda infeliz
fazendo o que eu fazia
embora no conforto da minha gaiola
mas eu teria desperdiçado 500 dias de
uma viagem onde eu pude vivenciar outras
culturas o que ampliou a minha noção de
certo e errado conhecer essas escolas
que expandiram a minha visão não só
sobre educação é sobre a vida encarar
novos desafios profissionais que me
tiram do conforto constantemente gerando
crescimento contínuo que me faz sentir
viva me faz sentir que estou evoluindo e
talvez o mais importante de tudo
aprender a conviver com medos incertezas
e perceber que isso já não me paralisa
mais porque se a gente olhar pro lado tá
tudo mudando tá tudo se transformando
constantemente
que garantias a gente realmente tem em
um mundo que está passando por rápidas e
constantes transformações
agora sei que o verdadeiro sentimento de
segurança não vende nenhuma gaiola vem
da confiança nas nossas próprias asas
vem da certeza de que a gente é capaz de
aprender e de se reinventar
quantas vezes for necessário muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]